and we're not selling out we have taken
on a minority investment
TSG know on 22% of her business and
that's going to allow us to go even
faster and take our company to the next
level
you've been quite scathing in the past
though of independent Brewers who've got
into bed with big partners for example
Camden Brewers when they were bought by
avian but if you stopped stocking them
yeah exactly so there's a huge
difference here they were bought by a
big industrial beer company one of the
type that's been a responsible for and
the commoditization of beer and they saw
that your entire business all we've done
is taken on a minority investment that's
gonna allow us to continue to run the
company in the way we want to it's from
a financial partner it's a first a beer
company and it's going to allow us to
continue to invest their beer in our
people which are the two things that are
most passionate right but you're still
selling a stake to the man aren't you
effectively and I don't see it that way
I mean it's not a satellite if it was a
sellout
I'd be gonna wait sit in a beach
somewhere as opposed to work as hard as
I possibly can for the next 5 or 10
years to make sure this business
fulfills its potential and we find a
partner who's aligned who wants to do
things the same way that we can and
we've got so many immediate
opportunities and this investments going
to help us capitalize on those and give
us the firepower to compete with the
global multinational beer companies the
global skill have you had lots of
approaches of this kind in the past yeah
we've had loads of a cultures and
financial ambassadors from strategic
investors from bigger beer companies and
we've never found a partner who we
thought was aligned in terms of how we
do things until we found TSG so we're
really excited about the next chapter in
their company's history with this new
deal so what was different about this
approach then well for us TSG were
aligned on investing to drive results
they did the deal with a long term time
horizon it's a minority investment so I
remain the largest shareholder myself
Americans still control the company and
they're completely aligned with their
equity
community as well so we have 55,000
equity Punk investors who are the heart
and soul of our business and we've
helped us develop the business we don't
have to do what your ambitions for the
business going forward then what's this
extra capital going to enable you to do
well we've got so many growth
opportunities in the UK and
internationally so this is going to
enable us to build capacity to adverse
in the UK and the u.s. we're also
looking to build a production facility
in Asia and allow us to ultimately
continue with our core mission which is
to make other people as passionate about
fantastic beard as we are will you
market the beer in exactly the same way
that you have done in the UK and
elsewhere yes so the America Angus is
what we what we believe in and as a
company we've never cleared too much
what people think we make beers if you
love ourselves and the marketing is just
how we want to do things and and that's
definitely not going to change and how's
the business trading on an underlying
basis at the moment James I mean
obviously the dollar has risen quite
sharply against the pound a lot of the
hops that you use a presumably source
from the states and paid for in dollars
and yes they are and we've also just
spent about 30 million dollars building
our new facility in Columbus Ohio
so exchange dates have had a bit of an
impact but overall the businesses in
your dually good shape are UK sales do
buy a hundred percent last year and
they're forecasting to do the same this
year so the challenge for us is that
just keeping up with your Jotham ensure
that we can build capacity build
infrastructure and add enough good
quality people so that we can fulfill
our ambitions this year and beyond